on a daily basis here at 8 news now we
get dozens of emails and phone calls
regarding
individual problems with unemployment
and we have been trying to help
all of you that are reaching out to us
joe moeller spoke with top deter
officials today
to try to get some of your questions
answered he joins us live to go over
some of the top concerns joe
we talked about a number of topics
including claimants who have been
waiting several months for their
benefits and also those overpayment
notices that
went out earlier this week deters says
they did go out for a number of reasons
either because
you were claiming in pua or regular ui
when you were supposed to be in the
other
or your income did not match the
statement submitted now the strike force
leader says if you do think anything is
wrong
in the notice which it is possible it
could be an error and you should appeal
we have heard from dozens if not
hundreds of you who have been waiting
from the beginning for benefits
leaders at the department say they are
looking into older claims that may have
fallen through the cracks
they are asking the newly appointed
administrator to provide a list of those
unresolved claims
i think the people who reach out to you
and reach out to us
they're the ones that are falling
between the cracks and we've got to get
every one of those resolved is there
any time frame you could put on that i
mean it's our hope for the pua system
to do all of these in the next two weeks
i mean we feel like we're at the bottom
of of uh resolution for pua
and then we want to put the extra
resources the labor
on the ui claims and then do the
automation changes from sb3 to clear out
another 20
000 from ui
now that interview was well over 30
minutes we will have the complete
interview up on our website
eightnewsnow.com but coming up here at
five o'clock we'll have much more
on the appeals process as well reporting
live joe moeller eight news now